awesome night tonight from Shania she
gave yellow nine how did that feel
getting under nine from tonight at Twain
I love you Shania I mean thank you so
much I love all the criticism and in the
positive I love everything I take it all
this feedback that's gonna help us get
stronger so we're gonna work on
everything the judges said we made a
decision to go a little bit more
ferocious with our dance and I'm hoping
everyone out there really loved it
you're at the halfway point how does it
feel halfway I know we have we now have
more dances and it gets a little tougher
now you know you got to split your
rehearsal in two and and think about all
the extra work that we have going on but
it's fun like we have like in the entire
competition there's only four weeks left
and we would love to be here as as far
as possible and as long as possible
because we're having so much fun I mean
the one thing I love about next week
with the team has to we're all one big
happy family here like we really support
each other we're all trying to push each
other do our best now we can actually
dance on the same team together I think
that's going to be amazing
yeah so it's the next week's the first
I'm doing two dances in one night are
you nervous excited no I'm excited
it's gonna be good it's gonna be a lot
of work but it's gonna be so much fun
awesome now were you big finish and i--i
growing I mean she's Canadian massive
huge fan so one of my first dances was
to man I feel like a woman and and that
question don't impress me much because
I've been a fan of her since I was a kid
and the leopard print that she wore in
that and her hair and she had a hood and
she was in a desert and she had boots on
and there was this guy that looked
gorgeous but that that didn't impress
her she was she's a rock star
I love her she's amazing and I mean
growing up in Canada as well all of
Canada love Shania my mom in the
audience tonight all the screaming you
heard that was my mom for her